here's a beacon what guests had to say
after the show okay these are the
questions that have been wired in from
the people out there who were probably
wired Carl on last night's Two and a
Half Men it was clear you and the lovely
Holland Taylor make beautiful music
together how about a spin off haha you
know something those wonderful sexual
lines I was the dirtiest old man I've
ever been in my life I'm not that kind
of a dirty Oh the writers wrote the best
dirty jokes I've ever seen I was I was
wildly fun from a guy who had to keep
robbing Laura Petry in separate beds
they couldn't even sleep in the same bed
fifty years ago your head must spin when
you see the kind of jokes they do at
eight o'clock at night on broadcast TV
yeah I don't know I sit with Mel Brooks
every night we said you believe he's the
guy who farted on in a movie and making
every time I says look what they're
doing Isis you started with the farty
you Robinson uh okay uh I asked you last
year a number time why you wanted to
keep the Patriot Act you said you did
not want to be called this is for you
representative Grayson you did not want
to be called unpatriotic knowing what
you know now about the NSA would you
change your vote hmm good question well
even the people who wrote the Patriot
Act and are responsible for it right I
think that it's not Brenner
yes sensor burner as it believes that
it's gotten completely out of control I
mean the Patriot Act is being used as an
excuse for setting up a state where
literally the Defense Department gets a
record of every phone call that we make
right it's there's no threat to national
security what I'm calling my mother
right I swear it I swear
part of the problem is though as we've
discovered through what Snowden is
revealed is that we don't we don't know
even what we don't know I mean when we
had another one of the documents in
addition to the domestic surveillance
stuff it was just the budget of
intelligence agencies how much we're
actually spending in broad categories
that we had no idea before we had note
they refused to give sort of a breakdown
of the numbers of what we're spending
money on and it doesn't make us any
safer it really doesn't you know they
float this number out that they have
somehow impeded fifty-plus terrorist
activities they use all these buzzwords
and peated activities it shows you that
their line just by the words that they
use and then you drill down into it
Justin Amash a Republican congressman
drilled into it and found that there was
actually only one one that they could
even argue our claim was was interfered
with and it wasn't even a Terran attack
it is the Credo of spy agencies not to
brag about their victories the CIA what
that's true that's that's part of the
problem when you're in the CIA you never
get the pat on the back because it's not
like a soldier where it's out front I
mean you have to just do it for the love
of your country yes but it's very hard
to know exactly what they're stopping
and what they're not yes but build that
kind of thinking leads to a 10-year
occupation of Iraq yeah I know well
there there there are there are
reasonable steps to take to keep us safe
and then there's all that other stuff
they're doing right and we don't have to
say what we can we can't be safe unless
every piece of mail is photographed yeah
unless the the Defense Department gets a
record of every phone call that every
American makes that just doesn't make
any sense okay dr. Emmanuel every single
Western country that consistently ranks
higher than the US and statistics from
the World Health Organization has
universal health coverage and then it
asks how can Republicans deny such
in-your-face evidence well maybe this is
more for you but I mean that is true we
I think the UN ranks us 37th 50th and
life expectancy but 37 I'm sorry that's
not then we pay the most yes as same
labels wonder how we we can pay so much
and get so little right I mean it seems
like you know almost anything would be
better than the system we have where the
350 dollar hip replacement cost 30 grand
was all I was trying to get at before
yes no I do think look almost everyone
who's involved in the health care system
believes we can do better in terms of
quality and we can save money we do have
to create the right incentives and I you
know the Affordable Care Act went a long
way towards that but didn't solve every
problem but it certainly was better than
what we had and I don't think there's
anyone who thinks what we had was
defensible it was high-priced
uneven quality and I would say that the
Republicans and I put this out never had
a plan to improve the quality ensure
everyone and reduce the cost they never
had a credible alternative so great
you may not like every part of the
Affordable Care Act but it gets us on
the road going up and improving and
that's the key and you know most of us
would also like we'd like to make tweaks
we'd like to make adjustments but given
the toxic nature in Washington even
adjustments that both sides can agree to
can't get enacted ok Matt we're gonna
give you the last question in the last
word because you deserve it come here
hostile territory
[Applause]
what do you say to people like Paul
Krugman who say that debt reduction is
not nearly the crisis you say it is and
hasn't it been proven that austerity is
actually bad for our economy
I don't think wealth comes from
Washington and it certainly doesn't come
from borrowing money that we don't have
it doesn't come from spending money that
was sometimes wealth does come from
borrowing money right that is true
that's called the stock market it's
called the private sector it's different
though because we we now have 17
trillion dollars in national debt and we
print money from the Federal Reserve to
offset that it distorts markets it
steals money we literally out of
people's pockets and at some point we
got to get a decision making again where
we choose between guns and butter after
2001 where the Republicans and Democrats
came up with this bipartisan collusion
where the Republicans got all the guns
they wanted and the Democrats got all
the butter they wanted and now we have
17 trillion dollars in debt and it falls
on the next generation this is a thing
that the deficits actually shrinking
right now it's shrinking faster than
than was expected health care costs are
going down more than we thought these
guys um yes yeah but it's the debt still
go no no of course in the long term that
is but in terms of the trajectory of
spending it is going down there were
three things that drove us into debt the
wars in Iraq and Afghanistan the Bush
era tax cuts and Part D the Medicare
drug payment which was not fine
all of those
all of those under President Bush
President Clinton handed President Bush
actually positive cash flow
we were actually not having deficit we
were gonna retire the day and then he
decided it would better that what Matt
would say to that if I could give you a
little chant leave here thank you is
that that's President Bush that's why we
started the Tea Party I remember it was
only a couple of years ago when I used
to have tea people I'm sorry Tea Party
people people from the tea lagoon teeth
party people on and they would say we're
not Republicans we can't tell us what
party were a part of we're completely
independent we might be Democrats well
those days are over on today I mean but
there does seem to be a trend here led
by mr. Ted Cruz where the tea party
people are happy to say we are not push
Republicans and you old school
Republicans can go [ __ ] yourself and
that that civil war is illumine oh it's
a common oh it's like it's like the
beginning of Gone with the Wind isn't it
I think it's awesome you think what's
odd I think it's awesome I think we are
repopulating the Republican Party with
people that actually stand for something
they said they were gonna do something
about the debt they came here to do it I
think they said that they were going to
balance the budget they're actually
trying to do it we're driving right off
a cliff right now and nobody seems to
care about the fact that we have so much
debt if you look at entitlements you're
talking about health care
you look entitlements or consuming a
larger and larger portion of the entire
federal budget it's crowding out all of
your guys favorite program I agree with
you need to be concerned about the
long-term debt but the best way to get
your hands around the long-term debt is
to fix the health care cost problem now
every I've ever and that's why we never
they did it first dad why we did the
Affordable Care Act job argument in the
about why you nobama do the economy
first that is the economy that's right
thank you very much everybody whoever
Real Time with Bill Maher Friday night
at 10:00 asked Bill and his guests who
are questions right after the show at
hbo.com